Furyk's bag verax bag oh my god might
see Tov in the future I don't know the
verdicts but they're actually good god
it's this whole season is like a big
reunion I mean it's like Zuko's a lot
this whole seasons like a big apology
for season it's it's like zoo goes alive
um we may have a tough way yeah I do it
I dare your freedom prophet it will
happen time yeah at least flashback and
verax back and and even Julie in the
background was good to see her um and
yeah we're getting pretty much what is
is that they break the kid out and they
leave the earth Queen and they go to
this kingdom that's made entirely out of
metal not tightly but mostly it looks
like odds to me it looks like a mix
between Oz and Gondor yeah like in this
beautiful metal flower it's it's gods um
and uh and then they find out that Lynne
has a sister half-sister she's and it
was she in charge of the city or running
so where she husband Simon her husband's
the architect she built the city okay
she wanted to start a family after
sailing the world
yeah owner Michael just just like top
they've ended up creating like just
another one of those most amazing
characters ever I'm like how the hell
did she get money to just create that's
not like just a little play it's like a
gigantic see all these stuff on her show
she'd probably want treasure hunting
maybe this is its I know I know um I'm
just suspicious if there's anything this
do be shows of tambien cards to be
suspicious
oh I suspect that Airbender who showed
up at uh yeah I show you Ted yeah I know
I said at first I didn't recognize I
called him suspicious McGee yeah that it
was like oh it is the guy
sister-sister yeah they don't know he
knowed everyone let's see pretty damn
obvious yeah no no it's um you recognize
him oh no for me I'm all those people
that if you cut the hair or you just
give a prison glasses out for over I
would totally fall for Clark
okay what Clark no no I totally would I
really would a lot of actresses I don't
recognize cuz they'll do their hair
different way of just cool witchcraft so
soon
so um and we find out there's some sort
of damage history between the two
sisters and Lin especially just wants
nothing to do with the family and we
don't know why we also know that that
trio of turning into a soap opera but in
like a good way cuz like I want to know
yeah it was like a bad soap up or where
I'm like I don't care those uh because
three people are for the criminals that
is gay before that it's for um and that
they got this I think it's like one of
each element say they got sewn with a
third eye way with another third eye
prison which is great I always wonder
what just what the hell those things are
those people are and we do because we
always saw one before and it's great to
see another one
I miss that sound that's a surprisingly
kind of scary sounded well they did
mention Zuko mentioned that it was the
same type of person like the assassin
here yeah no but it's like what are they
I mean how do what is that I and how
they have those powers I'm really
fascinated by that um so I hope they go
more into that if they don't it's like
okay but I'd like to know um so yeah I
mean this season is uh the the layout is
still beautiful I love that city that
assesses that you know yeah I mean I
love the I love Republic City
um and I loved it a lot in season one I
I didn't have an issue with it being
entirely in the city I I know you did
but I it is nice to get out like like
The Last Airbender did where you see all
the other cultures and then we get a new
culture the the Metalocalypse or the you
know metal APPA lists or whatever and
what i like is that there's always sir
this big you know and you can see why i
mean we have become consumed with like
metal and tall buildings and stuff like
that but then there is always this thing
it's like just metal bad and you know i
mean we've seen this in tokine and a lot
of fantasy where it's just like you know
metal evil gears wheels and stuff and
it's nice
something where it's like it's a city
made of metal but it's very it almost
looks like plant life and it's in it's
spaced out and doesn't consume
everything sort of like it looks like
some sort of early drawing for Epcot
centers yeah I'm good it's got the 1960s
futuristic thing going oh whichever I
really like that it's not like you know
I think grad there's already kind of
metal bending you know uh before I
certainly would land and stuff like that
but the to see a hole like whatever a
town made out of metal and it's not like
and it's not Republic City pretty much
you know it's actually something that's
very unique and very much its own
identity it's not like a mix between
Republic City and the the earth Kingdom
um so yeah and core again is I mean a
rational human being you know but still
high hat I I think that ya know like I
love when she was getting pissed like
frickin stupid queen in there ya know
and I always you know cuz I don't know
cuz you don't seem any likable hotheads
uh it shows and movies didn't this until
now yeah I shouldn't say that I thought
first season coral yeah like a season
sort of setting up and establishing um
so she's fine we got the split between
uh
tension and and the rest of me is gonna
go back and be a teacher now which I was
sort of like those splits when it's like
a Care D been for a while saying now we
have two very Empire Strikes Back one's
going to go by the others going to climb
sunset and everything it's actually but
they split up the airships I'm under
your orders are like I'll meet you at
the rendezvous point at Tatooine or
something but it fell out it felt big
somehow I give him they'll typically
nothing too huge has been going on yet I
mean at least in terms of like the
characters arts and everything it still
felt kind of big okay that's the writing
like let's really think about it what
has happened that's so epic probably
just the jailbreak hmm always will then
think about we we have had nothing but
interpersonal drama ya know and we have
which is and it works because we care
about the characters again I you know a
part of me is sore a saying like I would
like to get to you know like I said with
the second season again
it is a touch of an issue that I'm not
seeing like I mean that second season
real billion you know the spirit world
in the human world and what will it be
in stuff in oh I love them can airbend
that's kind of it oh there's also this
incredible holy shit stuff going on you
know if Republic City but it's like
she's no good that's let's go do this
um now but get its vote I'll get back to
it it's good and I don't know if they
will I think this is gonna be the focus
I don't know they keep mentioning the
words harmonic convergence I like you I
think the gold-seekers mention ectoplasm
so the the airbending thing seems to be
the main focus I don't know if they're
gonna go well there can I have to solve
the fact that the city's covered under
vines somehow you don't start off a
season like that and don't have it
resolved I don't know I just see it as
they go back it's even worse
like just at the very end they're like
Korra we need you back and it's like oh
you got a home you're after all maybe
that'll be the next season or something
okay but I mean they're gonna resolve it
at some point I guess but it's I mean it
made - honestly they resolve it in the
next season that's fine
maybe we'll have like an over arching
story arc again instead of like you know
no that's fine but I'm also sort of like
I did to do with this one but again
maybe they do need a space with the
spirits because we did see so many in
the in the last season who knows Nick is
messed up this show so much like we're
lucky I love at the end we're gonna get
on anything out that's you know good
because they've dipped these poor
creators around so much like I I feel
bad that we rip on the second season but
I mean legitimately the second season
has issues but a lot of that falls on
Nickelodeon they can these guys can only
do the best with what they're handed are
told at the last second what I actually
even though like I had I agree with a
lot we you said about the second season
I don't think I disliked it as much as
you do
oh like if you cut out the whole middle
part of the second season I actually
would think it's fucking yeah like I
feel like the second season should have
been seven episodes like it just like it
started off great and then in the middle
it just was for focus my gosh yeah um
but but not but with this one it
one thing I was noticing is missing and
I'm hoping verdict can help with this
Vera Vera cancer yeah I'm hoping Vera
can help it is um I don't think it's
that funny and I don't mean like they're
not trying to make you laugh because
they are and I you never believed in
Bolin I hisako light I want to like him
but and I don't hate him I don't hate
him but music he suck a light he really
is
um no but not definite the earth Queen
causally sneezing and stuff like that
like they're they're definitely trying
some jokes which is fine you know I keep
it light not like every joke in you know
Avatar work or even Korra but honestly
humor was just for the most part so good
and Oz if they sort of don't want to do
the humor out that's fine but it isn't
it is like man yeah these are just
really kind of missin I'm not really
missing it
no not like am i interested in the
characters yeah do I need them to be
funny 24/7 now as Sokka light does his
job and he's interesting and whatever he
may have going now with uh you know the
nice fair wind beifong's me see that I
who knows where that's going maybe he's
finally gonna get some and not either
muck it up himself or have her be a
crazy psycho or you know maybe it's
finally his moment of you know but once
uh well the thing I think honestly less
humor is not a problem it I didn't need
more necessarily and and ah it's not God
all for humor it's not like oh god are
you kidding or anything but the same
time it is like I'm watching a lot of
these jokes in Lobby sees I mean there's
some scenes where they'll have like five
jokes on top of each other I'm like yep
come on guys you can do you know you're
you're good at this you're good at
writing humor it would be great for we
get anything oh I'm very glad bearings
back uh as soon as I saw I was like yeah
it was just cuz that was something I was
missing because it week I was so pissed
too and he just was like written off at
the end they're like well goodbye and
I'm like what no cuz that's why saying I
was like really just desert good
hey good yeah if you've really
disappeared into the night I was like oh
come on that's very good not in the nod
for a second am i absolutely sure that
was planned I'll give them the benefit
of that'd be like oh that was brilliant
that was when they may have just been
like a pet frog oh they may have like
read the reviews and like oh he loves
his guy let's bring him back but
whatever the hell it was like good job
yeah no I mean I'm sure just bring him
back we I watched that with Doug and my
wife just now like we literally
applauded like yeah school kids
ridiculous but it that is another thing
the second season that even though we
had issues with it I think was always
strong was the comedy uh as well um no I
do miss I do miss the twins they're
briefly as inert wins
fado is so good uh and very gay oh
really majority of the new characters
they introduced in second season were
good
funny enjoyable characters uh but
honestly for I'm more way more
interested in these villains than I was
in her uncle as of on the second one and
all the new characters they've
introduced tofs extended family now ya
know I don't even mind the kid I liked
fine do whatever but like every new
character they've introduced maybe
outside of the Queen the Queen was
getting on my nerves I'm kind of glad
we're past that at least for a little
while but you know all of them like
really interesting character yeah where
I from the twins and and Varrick I felt
there was just sort of a all right
like I think the weakness was the
villain maybe that's what yeah I wasn't
the villain because yeah cuz the film
lasts uh the last season well was such a
retread and it was pretty weak um I
think it's great to see like cuz at
first I'll seeing this guy and the
airbending guy and I'm like yeah and
like we'll see I'm judging too early and
stuff and when he stopped us or look
around and look at the culture and he
knows a lot about this and he's I don't
know I like the respect of that culture
he had enough to even know the moves
it's like what is his backstory it was a
poetry yeah and he doesn't look at like
you know yes I will destroy all of this
I said there is or this was bad
for which I kind of now is an oh shit
moment when he's there in front of a kid
like with the with the poetry in his
hand and you're just like what's he
gonna do
oh yeah baby holy got a smile for yeah
it was really kind of creepy like is he
just gonna take her out now run off with
her and then you know we end up with a
nice fight which is also really nice
because one thing I did miss um
particularly in the first two seasons is
the airbending I missing that angst
aisle of fighting and we've got it like
we just have someone we got it
everywhere yeah no it's great I missed
that like cuz obviously last airbender
was all about the Airbender I feel like
we were just kind of missing that you
know for the most part and the other
ones even though she's been trying to
learn but yeah I bet now we've got
full-on real kick-ass airbending fights
and it's awesome the kids are still
really fighting to the little bald kid
teaching them how to air yes yeah is
great I mean that's exactly what you
want to see and why is Charlie Brown
teaching us um so yeah I'm trying to
think there's any other drama dad we we
can get Emily dodging and Nickelodeon
yeah don't you go to see online yeah you
can't see it online and it's like yeah
wonder what you're pushing this over
oh so I know what to think of an honest
look if it kind of seems like it is that
Nickelodeon's like a rudderless ship it
will he is I don't know what is going on
over there they're turning into like the
freakin DC of like kids Network sigh
it's just starting to - Cod a little
yeah every day just with Korra I don't
watch the rest of them channel I have
made the rest of its Incredibles they
just fun quality on epic
I somehow doubt that I think the best
thing they got on right now is probably
TMNT but the newest yes many version 4.0
which I have seen someone's actually not
bad but I like when they get a good
thing going like there's no problem with
Cora Cora has respect it is critical
acclaim of this is and they have this
wonderful product here based on a
franchise that they had back a few years
ago that has also just been this
international success of like what are
we gonna do with this I don't know how
do we screw this up find a way to do it
like I hear she's gonna be in a ball pit
I just found out about this Conda this
will be 100% dated like in a week I'm
sure but it's I just taught you he had
to tell me apparently about this guy
when we went to a good con we're gonna
call up with Farah yeah we didn't get to
talk to her but she was there a Janet
Janet Varney Varney yeah actually that
was a blast because we they did a voice
acting panel she's very funny
she's very um Rob Paulsen Maurice
LaMarche was Janet Varney Anderson I
can't remember that dudes name I always
just call him centers him like an
asshole
this isn't like he's like I have a real
name you already had a good sense of
humor he'd be fine but uh yeah and the
funny thing was I was telling dougie
afterwards we had to duck out early
because we had a panel of our own to get
to um I didn't want to tell her fans we
were watching better more talented
people something we couldn't talk to you
guys but you know like Maurice LaMarche
and Rob Paulsen you know Rob Paulsen
kind of sounds like Raphael from thb
Ninja Turtles but Maurice LaMarche has
like a normal voice so a lot of times
it's like a put-on
with the voice like they're doing
impressions they get into a certain zone
for the voice Janet Varney and she she
just sounds like Korra and it was really
amazing but also surreal because it was
like you just had Korra answering random
questions I mean just random questions
about what your favorite food is and
stuff like that you know and it was just
it was an interesting experience she's
got a great sense of humor too yeah um
so knows that I go and apparently is
a fan told us out of it's true but
apparently she's heard of these viewings
oh we're sorry yeah like she's always
make it like all the episodes it's not
your fault is the voice acting is great
oh well we still like the show we do
like the show i even i you know i say
season to his problems but I would never
say it's bad
yeah I'm entertaining like almost
anything else on television yeah I mean
I think when I mean with even with the
avatar you know he logs and like the
Adventure Time is definitely when we
talk about something it's bad it's sort
of like by their own standards by the
incredibly high standards they built uh
which is why it's so nice when they
actually continue to hit those standards
like they are in this season um and yeah
it is interesting like it's mostly
family dynamic stuff up but I'm
interested and it's surprisingly not
want to know what that backstory is with
tofs family yeah I mean you know before
it's like you can't live a falling to
cry I'm like oh my god that wasn't big
one to me the big knows where she tells
the nice to piss off i i'm yeah i was
like jimmy like oh pretty shocked at
that i'm like wow well the holes these
the awkward dinner scene like i was like
oh shit not pulling any punches are we
hmm yeah so it's i say the only other
thing i can think of uh the top of my
head cuz i was thinkin like wait a
minute what why would she hire Varick
you know cuz he is you know it was a not
convicted presidential kill maybe maybe
the metal may be metal apples is like
switzerland it's just neutrality and
he's got immunity
why i was gonna say too with her
backstory they show very much she went
along her own way and she like she was
what the performing group then she was
with pirates that she decides what she's
and she hired a pirate exactly so i
think nobody even that us are like is
that wise but you see that she probably
really has gone through this life of
doing though and maybe that's what's
also pissing Lin beifong I was gonna say
or she's plan to be the popcorn guy
um it could be I mean they don't know if
she's eating something a chance of being
a villain then that is also redemption
for season two where everybody literally
looked at the uncle and was like ten
seconds into like villain like I was
like like this this would be quite the
twist yeah this I don't know I don't
know how they're gonna do it I'm not
sure if I want them to because I really
like the character no I don't want them
to either but it's a possibility the
fact that I could look at that as a
possibility shows how much better the
quality of this season it yeah no I
agree
um so yeah uh try and think any other
closing thought series ya know come the
only thing that confuses me is our main
villain didn't know how to ever been he
gets the powers via harmonic convergence
magic by the way I gotta say sometimes I
feel sorry for voice actors cuz how do
you say that with any tainted melodic of
harmonic convergence well I was able to
split the spirit when I went into your
harmonic convergence is like saying
lines like that you just got to be
sitting in the Sun with going like oh
man that's pretty rough but he gets it
from the harmonic convergence
mononucleosis thing or whatever and it
implies that he was studying airbending
but if this is kind of like a martial
art and Taichi I would think that you
would have to learn this by watching and
doing and training and not getting it
out of a book he gets some basic things
out of a book but he seems really adept
at this for not having studied under any
sort of teacher that maybe he did and
taken away by some magic or whatever I
it could be like maybe they're gonna
write that in at the end that's the only
big question mark over my head at the
moment I'm it's like how do you there's
a lot I don't know a story at all so I'm
really fascinated yeah I'm like how did
he get that good I'll be interested to
see what they come up with so yeah and
that's the great thing I'm really
interested to see what they're coming up
with like there is that moment in the
middle of the second season where I just
kind of lost interest and it's like it's
good to give an Emirati back to show
again yeah and they brought it back but
the thing is I wasn't looking forward to
it I was I still
wasn't looking forward to in the sense
that once people told me oh no this
episode is because we tend to be an
episode or two behind yeah you know once
they said the internet exploded Saigon
oh it's the whole backstory of you know
how bending came to me and it's really
amazing I don't watch it then I was into
it but I I wasn't assuming it was going
to be great because it just was kind of
yeah yeah but yeah not this season I
just ya know I'm definitely interested
uh yeah I can't wait to see where it
goes next won't you join us
yes